you
and we are loved welcome to the last
word with Lord Candido and Ibanez
special Friday new DLC Edition a new
expansion do Annual Pass at this event a
how are you doing man uh it's been crazy
couple of days mostly just the fact that
I've got family coming in town this
weekend so just gonna be watching trials
from afar cuz that lunch is in hours
four of them to be little exact about it
and yeah I've been working on leveling
up experience the new tower and public
events and kind of getting a feel for
the season and definitely getting ready
to get the grind on so are you how you
doing man I mean considering the real
life circumstances that everybody's been
going through yeah virus that we will
not name for D monetization purposes
yeah but um yeah man I mean at the end
of the day it's just like you know I
will say this you know being a I've
never been as happy be a gamer and now
because if you can imagine you know if
you're a guy who is solely just into
sports if you're a person who is solely
into just physical activity based on
what is going on in the world right now
you know being a game is kind of cool
right now cuz you know you could yeah
live it up on the indoors and be like
cool it is necessary man I definitely
you know taking advantages so sleeping
alone over the place a lot of stuff
going on I was the cancellation sad face
III but um just you know kind of moving
things around adjusting and then
obviously but you know I text you and
you know how I feel about GC accent you
know how I'm dying to go back to DC x
that's literally our origins as a
podcast you mean and um you know one
could just hope you know right now they
have not made the official announcement
but um they just said kind of like
they're I know now we can see god I'm
old right pretty much I mean that's
that's a feeling all they can do at this
point I mean it's farther away they're
not quite the scale of some of these
like major events that aren't gonna
attract like tens of thousands per se I
mean it grows every year so who knows
that
it's gonna be but they do have a point
where it's probably you know you can't
hold 50,000 people at gcx it just ain't
gonna fit so it is on the smaller side
but also on them they have probably my
guessing of smaller backing so when it
comes to like cancelling or you know
falling back or just like the financial
hit it's gonna be it's gonna be bigger
for them because it's on them and they
built this thing themselves
I mean value Roman in that whole rare
drop group building this and then from
next to nothing so it's when it's facing
something like this it's when it's hard
because it's so personal that's the
human element right there so we'll see
what happens we will be monitoring you
know I'm saying but as far as that's
concerned I've been I've been in and out
I haven't been playing as much as I
would like to I am really behind the
light is low I'm gonna get most likely
light smash this we just walloped this
weekend yeah is that gonna be spooky but
I'll jump in there man I'm strapped my
boots on Lake Sam up get him get in
tight because trials is here trials is
here so the cool thing I've been doing
is really messing with loadouts messing
with the matter seeing what's work and
seeing what's feeling good and like my
boy Bobby so I said oh hey Arthur
looking for a strong right now man
Baylor's so what is your order your
loadout attempts what do you petitioner
trying cuz I mean yeah we'll talk about
the other stuff that launched already
but I mean the big top is coming at four
hours so what are you what are you gonna
try this weekend what are you testing
what's here what's your experimentation
because you're always a little off the
book you're like I know that a page that
everybody's reading on right now I'm
considering it but I want to look
outside even though I think bungee
jumped all over all your ideas like
bungee definitely yeah hatched out many
a change for you yeah everybody's all
it's a lot of the stuff I was doing oh
shout out to my boy meds man not to look
hot your brother love you bear love you
too brother
cool but please please be safe man
that's my bro oh yeah man like for me I
had some idea obviously we had to patch
notes that get dropped
the day of you know the expansion or
whatever the update and I had some
tricks I was thinking in my head of what
I wanted to do one of them was gonna be
top tree um
caller and immediately I noticed some
new nerfs you know nurse the grenades
big you know it was just a ton of stuff
that I'm like man I was I was thinking
of some really you know sweaty light up
for trials see they shut me down cuz a
arc web would have been very nasty in
its current form in his prior form but
that was one and then um you know so
pretty much right now I've been I was
experimenting just testing to see what I
could get away with with fusions with
shotguns stuff like that first you know
fusions felt a little different um I
will say not substantial enough that
they're not I didn't feel like wow I
can't use this anymore I'm just like
okay I know it's a slight you know I bet
you're not gonna map you're gonna be
happy you're gonna use them at Lake
basically shutting in a shotgun type you
gotta have you gotta use it in the right
place and if I mean they're trying to
steer some of these weapons to get back
where they intended them to be not be
big giant broken cross amending bolt
firing things yeah it's like they're
trying to steer things where they want
them even if it is like oh no my
favorite gun it's like they're like this
is where we want it in the first place
it's just been a little busted mmm
so yeah right now I'm kind of like
locked into two different loadouts you
know as far as what I'm rocking went on
just like I get actually it's kind of
older I'm not I'm not I'm not doing the
AR thing everyone's doing the a Arthur I
have that duty I refuse to be part of a
laser light show no hard like say no too
hard like it's a good a lot of people
that are gonna be there you're gonna be
seeing some laser lights I'm pretty sure
yeah I've already seen having I've been
catching a couple of elves to those you
know in some elimination warm-up table
doing a lot of that so pretty buggers
messing with strictly elimination comp
that kind of stuff is getting so they
are fun I've seen a lot of that snipe
the snipers out here then they killing
man they really do anything but for me
right now it's good old did you live
swing rid of it I had the old vigilance
is still doing what I needed to do and
I'm very close to my catalyst so I'm
just right there like almost you need
250 of my light
200 I'm getting there I want to get that
full auto a lot and then it's right now
it's looking like it's gonna be
vigilance and I'm yo the boy had a last
hope Oh almost God role in the vote so
dust that bad boy off man this is my
first time using side office since they
got buff I didn't use them the entire
season of the door II yeah
yo adaptive whoa was i sleeping
it's disgusting man so here Mars is like
a multi kill clip and we've got what the
the middle per I think I think it's raid
I wanted it to be better it's like
rangefinder which is not bad and a multi
kill clip loving that and then for heavy
I'm going with Old Faithful hammerhead
with the rampage you know I'm saying
spec on it you know I'm saying just keep
it safe keep it basic keep it efficient
but I'm doing so that that's the first
line up the second one like I said if
things if things go sour quick like get
an idea it's like the Mike Tyson had an
idea and then you get punch there is
like I gotta find something new it were
covered up I get punched in the mouth
backup plans will be super sweaty
I might have to dust out the law yeah
but I dusted off base still ice it's
still pretty effective you don't say I
just don't I haven't heard too much I
don't know how it got hit yeah people
people ever using it but I've dust that
off and um the 540 540 SRC you feel
still feel good the UH
the outlast he calls claws of the wolf
that kind of stuff both in yeah then I
run with a little shoddy giant pod on it
all feel good I was a little
disappointed laughing au sable and I'll
give it to you um little disappointed in
the 720 in PvP maybe it's just me I had
a guy steal for the repeater but um well
I bested me for right now have terrible
EVPs because I know
playing trials this weekend yeah fax fax
I know you've been all be all PvE ya
doing got the video out you got
everything going so so what's going on
man we've been you know let's get into
it like we've been talking obviously you
know but texting and stuff and you've
been giving me mixed signals sir
oh just a feedback on different things
so we launched in get our little story
cinematic which is cool let's go oh
there we go we see the floor of the
world open up little bunker down there
as we go to so we go to check with
Hannah brain that we talk arrest your
ass Putin we get to sent to another
bunker the bunkers on the adze that
opens up from the ground and be like
what's up come on down see how quickly
you could drive your Sparrow down these
little Tom I love that boy like that and
you come down you're like and I actually
saw on Twitter somebody pointed out that
the animation was actually shackles I
think shotgun the animation of the
monitors that light up when you're
looking at the bunker when you're
looking a tribute ins bunker the
monitors follow you like an eye
really
and I gotta pay attention Wow I don't
like that he be buzzing in is Russian my
heat boy like yo wrasse you got a chill
bro like you to it did you buzz in my
language man a little too imposing yeah
actually so shout-out to 9 hydras on
Twitter awesome artists there every
Bungie and he was actually saying he had
couple help from a couple people in the
studio for like the math to say it's
like okay from the center point so where
the players at like shading most of them
down but lighting up certain ones and
like showing basically that like
whichever way you're facing there's like
a usual about three or four monitors
that will always track and phases like
Lily nuances of stuff like that you
don't realize mm-hmm just give the world
always a little bit more life that you
don't quite may not even notice but it's
definitely there though absolutely so
then you go down dock to the bunker and
he's like hey gotta go clean this stuff
out real quick we got our daily bunker
which he didn't know until one day later
but you've got to clean out the bunker
every day that bunker now has champion
so the first time you get in there you
got the cinematic you got Anna you got
Zavala sitting under the bubble and then
you gotta clear out some captains and
stuff and you actually see them in a
mission which is can't think of the last
time you've actually been walking up and
they're just like sitting in the game
world doing their thing and I was like
not a cool kind of cool Danika shout is
a viola for blocking bullets with his um
his things lo shields along man that one
yeah when he's on the almighty just is
like wait for it okay see that giant
giant shoulder pad get at least one
bullet yes so it's been sitting out
there for a while we were waiting to see
if it's actually functional or fashion
--all mm-hmm and then after you kind of
cleared out with Anna you like link up
Rasputin you go back up the stairs you
talk to him you got bounties you got
upgrades and then there's a public
events you guys normally see in the
background if you're watching the video
if you weren't watching the video find
it on either of our YouTube channels
youtube.com slash Avant s or iron
it's podcast YouTube channel either one
um
but the big thing is you're throwing
orbs at an orb to get it to move in the
middle of the room or arena the lots of
organs going on and at first I was like
is this public event like more of a pain
in the butt that I realize the light
level of certain things and then kind of
got a feel for it and everybody figured
out what had to happen mmm there is no
heroic but I swear this is like as I
played a little bit longer not all
blueberries get it there's the video
there's multiple video follow did when I
did one there's multiple videos of how
to do this thing and not suck but I will
say people are getting better
consistently cuz I think just everybody
has to do the one thing the ones who are
doing it now two months from now a
blueberry trips into the season is like
oh what is this what do I do
yeah you're gonna be like dude where are
you why you throwing that ball what do
you what are you doing just like with
you assume people know but for now
lately at least I've had a reasonable
luck in the last like probably 36 48
hours on the public event going fairly
smooth I would say nice nice been
getting that uh you don't get those
angry messages from Anna and telling you
about these it's been over any
like damn did you see just little two
balls get thrown out you know you messed
up be like damn you know say but yeah
it's interesting be candid continue so
you do it so you did use doing that
messing around with that yeah so you got
that one you're starting to collect
currencies and then I'm just trying to
like lead into our discussion because
when we get into the discussion that's
when it'll get interesting well yeah
it's like you you clear the plates on
the public event that's the biggest
thing
and at first you're like oh that's not
too bad just some ads and then falling
invisible guys or sitting on the plate
and you're like why did we only get two
and you turn around and you're like that
didn't visible guy just being a pain in
my butt and then if you actually make it
through then you gotta fight the
champions and then there's a big giant
captain sitting on your plate who's a
boss that nobody will kill him cuz he's
got a crap ton of health then you
actually make it through the time with
the sneak left then you got two
champions nobody brought any mods with
them you're like oh I got a switch over
to my mod weapon to make sure we break
these champion barriers then you break
the champions if you finish with like
two seconds to go healing all right now
I gotta do it again
yep back at it back at it mmm and I say
that because my power level is
1976 1977 somewhere in that realm okay
alright we had to see Wow I thought
you'd be like yeah I'm literally dead I
mean I've got work I've been chopping I
got family coming in town I'm gonna be
I'm already buying this season so uh
yeah so power levels not crazy high
which means if you don't have a group
I'm definitely not soloing the legendary
lost sectors had logged it I logged into
one of those on like literally day well
and as soon as I had access to it I
walked in jumped up in the air
died vandal shot me on the other side of
the screen power love 1000 holy good
beating holy crap mmm don't there are
multiple things to talk about I'm gonna
throw a couple topics out then I'm gonna
let you just basically snatch one out of
the air so you get the pick first we got
republic event we've got the new
currency grind and got the power level
of some activities some we have access
through something we don't rots pick a
topic we'll just do it draw it out of a
hat
just mm-hmm which one you got um studio
tab between we said the power level and
the public event either one of those
to start a public event we can start
there it's the lightest are probably the
three was like I was like what do you
think
all right so startingly jump in um like
the aesthetic of it you know obviously
got the the plate
you know sanding it lights up like a hot
hot plate if you know if they get on it
um you know I thought it was pretty much
a game of don't get overwhelmed you know
I'm saying cuz they're going to come
they're gonna come from different size
stuff like that so you know roaming
supers all that stuff you know I will
say you know with the artifact and stuff
like that you know they are pushing
towards swords this is and I don't know
if you've been messing around well um
yeah yo
very impressed swords almost feel like a
little combo system now you like
boom-boom-boom like light yeah yeah it's
like okay you know we got a low flow so
I was messing around it was way more
effective you know and at that I don't
even have the I don't know at the time I
didn't have the overload brown which I
heard is crazy yeah yeah over Lois or
brown so you know it was interesting I
first trying to figure out what the hell
I'm supposed to be doing and then you
see the little ball the aim was a little
unforgiving you can completely with the
only accurate portrayal especially as
it's moving make sure like easiest way
to do it if you line up but it's like
shooting between the field goal it's
like if you actually just kind of come
around a line behind it it's only gonna
move that way not like yeah and across
your screen and yo if so yeah me nation
that's one of the things when I sat on
my polka minute video if it takes you
two or three extra seconds to throw the
ball and you don't waste it somebody
else finishes that tower and you move on
to the next one don't waste the balls
and I know that's right it's gonna be a
weird sentence and chat it to
man-at-arms on Twitter and he's like my
understanding of this season balls don't
waste the balls beat him yeah so those
are yeah don't want to miss now every
playground if it's clear you get six
yeah and then you can technically
complete that tower with six but right
nobody could miss and you're like
alright please don't miss don't miss and
then you're looking up there and the
ball is just hanging like one one orb
away for
that Center and you're like alright who
missed I know what me who dropped the
ball literally drop the ball literally
yeah oh yeah it's kind of like it is
definitely not forgiving now you can you
don't have to go perfect but it was nice
if you have a run that just goes like I
haven't had the public of it I haven't
had that what is it which is gonna be a
hard triumph to get but well like I
never heaven but I think
have every tower go perfectly like sixes
every time like you can't miss a ball
and you can't get overrun I think
there's a triumph i browse through like
you had to have to hit the Seraph tower
public event like perfectly mmm that's
gonna be rough
yeah a lot of coordination involved but
it's like even if it's not quite perfect
because haven't had it if you get a
group that's in sync it flows pretty
well like you have seven minute
countdown timer and I've done in five I
think
no no it's longer it's definitely one
you can't force I forget what I was
doing running around like on sigh I
think I was actually playing with Aries
who was in chat and my brother possibly
Tuesday night and we were on Io just
doing random public event because we
were looking on flashpoint I mean then
we were doing the taken one Aerys had
Wardenclyffe coil and then I had just a
cluster rocket with me but work left
oils the way to go that taken flight
public event when done correctly mm-hmm
just cuz I haven't seen it done as
perfectly as we nailed it like the
fastest public event it is fast usually
it is faster than that ship because you
don't have to wait on it right until big
boy comes in he gets smashed that's fast
if you won the first stage literally go
like forklift fork lift rocket rocket
nobody Golden Gun spawn the guy couple
supers and you're dead and it's dead
like maybe if you're good about it less
than a minute am oh yeah
though those are funny to see when
things go quickly and it's like you
can't force this Seraph public event to
be fast it's gonna be roughly five
minutes plus at least a minute cool with
coordination on those champions when you
make it through the minute
or when you make it through the tower
you get him up 200% you send on this
champion or two right and we were
talking about I was like I wonder what
the champions are gonna be yeah and we
joked about the servitor barrier
champion and they nailed that was like a
bunch of 800 who's shielding while he's
barrier shielded and you're like oh god
that is true that was not good and then
what it's overload captains
which don't seem as
how do I say this pushy as the minotaurs
they don't see as lake forward
aggressive cuz captain you know kind of
weenies but there's so I don't know
their function per se maybe I'll run
into him in a strike a little bit but
I know like describe they don't feel as
there's like I had like UNSTOPABLES just
like I'm coming at you yeah I'm coming
through load minotaurs is all I ever
remember and they were just like
teleport teleport teleport through a
strike or something like that don't like
the overloads weren't that common but
it's like the overload captain's just I
guess they're just kind of annoying you
have to keep the damage on them or yeah
system yeah more than anything
yeah recharge mechanic a get you been
good we add with the public events so uh
how how you feeling about it how you
gonna feel when you're running your
thousandth time like what are you what
do you got getting involved from even I
mean it right now again you know it's
the first week you know I I actually
liked it you know it's not the issue
that I see a lot of people have is also
you don't people say hey you know the
recycling content even though these
different game mechanics and stuff like
that you know tom is gonna tell you know
we're gonna tell he's gonna tell how
long we're gonna be invested in but I I
can see it as a situation that you know
we're just doing it for the necessary
part of the grind and stuff like that
the real reason the real thing key will
be all do we stick with it you know I'm
saying after it so you know and that
that may be very very baby don't you
knows it it may it may run its course
quick so you know they said there's
other stuff for the um the roadmap that
you know they haven't talked about stuff
like that but um initially you don't
saying for what I feel it's just like
have fun it's just like you're in arena
defend these boxes go here thrown up
thing then you get a couple of cool boss
fights at the end you know mindless fun
also lets you know what I were to say is
hey guys take advantage about he's there
take advantage of whatever social
weapons yeah do everything honest Const
about constant you know different
enemies and stuff like that well you
know g2 but at the end of the day it's
really cool to get a lot of things done
you know I got a lot of things done
during that space and even some of the
other the war from the war mind about it
well the warmind repeatable sir easy
it's just like inside they're gonna be
grenade kills super kills melee kills or
pick a weapon are you literally just
like every time you want to go you pick
up five four pupils go do the public
event you'll get six more mine bits you
do the repeatable balinese you give in
or if you've upgraded the thing you get
twelve run with different weapons rinse
repeat through it over and over and over
and over and over
I'm sorry video - mmm no this is part of
what I'm seeing police from the
community is here we go what you know
you know they get talked about no I'm
I'm in the dark like you're literally
educating me okay on how the community
five seats are you done with the bunker
not much I mean I got to level with two
I mean yeah I'm not at three yet I
didn't get a chance to weapon yet I'm
close to that's the well yeah um so I'm
very early you know um and just messing
around and looking at picking picking
the stuff that benefits you either in
cost or you know I'm saying stuff that
makes sense
not like vanity stuff you know I'm
saying but that kind of thing so um you
know it's early I felt like an obelisk
feel with certain things of it yeah you
know um the jury's out I I don't know
anything about the weapons that one you
know shout to Tassie we've had on you
know one minute it's like oh he's I was
a trash you know saying no I Daniel a
trash yes a and then other minute now
I'm like he put one out today
yeah he's like it like almost a mere
coma like oh well I may have been wrong
because these mods are kind of you know
this that in the third so um you know
it's early it's early but to your point
where I think you're going and where I
think the community might be sour and
the sour the sour
the sour great people are out yeah but
on I can understand people being
concerned about
stay stable ago it's not really a new
play space you literally just slept or
what you call it on you know in the area
and in this something I I can understand
that sentiment you know but we got to
see you know let's get into it tell me
what's going on I have to know what
people are upset about what's good uh so
I mean you got you had people get done
with freckling grinding a whole bunch of
that out you had the obelisk so that you
had to level up with the frack line
you're leveling up these little NPC non
NPCs like basically inanimate NPCs
however you want to phrase it
what's up for it I was over hmm so
people were doing that they leveled a
button they go through the season they
get them done they turn around and they
look at this thing in there like just
Ovilus 2.0 with the currencies now and
then the other thing is now the I would
say the
this season started and reminded me with
a feel of Borge
hmm okay okay when you start you have
two things you can do I guess yeah I
would say three you have a public event
just a little bit of a struggle at first
but people can get on board now me as a
solo player I hadn't really searched out
groups I know one of the guys who's
usually my twitch dad he was like hey I
found some groups even at 975 I was able
to do the legendary lost sector just got
to get some groups the coordinating I
get that
woo solo player random person who logs
in though this is like what they see
this season they're like okay public
event kind of get in a field legend
you're lost sector hey I go in I got
instantly killed what the hell that was
in power level I got to get out of here
okay so that's not on the table I gotta
get my power level up what do I do
all the old stuff this powerful gear do
I know my strengths my crystal matches
my do go do my bounties go do my stuff
on the moon from six months ago go and
it's it's a newer version of the force
like it the forge started and remember
the fort started too high that they
bumped a little bounce people get
experience the new content that was an
issue then when you turn around and look
at this one you're like hey it's a
public event
what's the other thing I could do and
the other reason I give a little
credence to this like little high level
of I know you can get a group together
but that legendary lost sector is a
thousand power level it's one of the
weekly bounties do you have to do to get
your Wow drop of the week you have the
public event you have to open that chest
four times legendary lost sector you
have to open that chest three times once
you use to open those chests you only
get from the daily boundaries there's
only four do you literally have to do
you can do four chest openings on the
public event gotta wait to my next day
for your dailies to open the other side
chests for the legendary lost sector if
you can beat it
just run --is-- the powerful gear grind
at the bunker last one then if a you're
like okay I want grind well I went to
the moon I did the story mission there
that's what I went to the altars of
sorrow I started doing all my I had a
lot of bounties saved so I've got all
that stuff done all of that stuff is
where some people were like I gotta go
do all the old stuff to do the new stuff
again to be a moon the new stuff so it's
like it's an interesting discussion
because again how much content can
destiny make that's word stuff they want
they wanted to put stuff that's a little
aspirational it's like hey they made the
public event 980 they made the legendary
lost sector a thousand like they wanted
to give stuff for people to reach for as
they level up a little bit but when you
log in you want to try new stuff so it's
like how do they how do they win that
battle and I feel like they're kind of
damned if they do and damned if they
don't what are you thinking about just
even that feeling of I gotta go grind
the old stuff to get high enough if I do
grind some of the new stuff it's such a
currency grind that I just got tired of
last season to take you into trying to
get into this season it's like it's more
currencies it's warmind bits the level
this thing up do with the warmind bits
by the upgrades in the buckler then the
bunkers give me chipsets chip sets up
the reputation that's how I actually get
a level that's oh I move this quest
forward right so that's kind of the info
jump so all of that to you but yeah I
mean
I get the sense of it I can I can I can
understand the sentiment for me right
now I'm having fun with the content it's
it's early but you know I am having fun
with it I think I I do understand that
people you know are gonna feel away that
like that this is good this is not that
the Annual Pass model is going to have
some content like this now I will say
this from the from what I've seen
initially you know with cinematics with
story building with leading in I feel
they're doing a much better job they're
doing a much better job in that
department you know as far as the you
know weapons and the nerves and stuff
we'll get into that you know we all know
the reason for that that's trials things
can't he's got to behave you know in a
good way but um dad man I mean look
they have to be careful that they don't
fall into patterns and one of them is
obviously this is a very obelisk II kind
of thing some people might not be into
this level of grind and I'm saying
that's one but it's the same at the same
time we can't say yo what's up with this
but you know and then we were
complaining about all sundial is like
menagerie 2.0 so to speak
so it's it's a they're in a tough spot
they were the test might as we well know
you know based on band we've been you
know things of that nature resources and
discussion so how much can be made I
want all my content right now but they
can't do it I don't want to crunch but I
want all my content forever and always
every day that's right but we don't want
to kill the developers how do we balance
that out nobody freaking knows either
don't worry we're confused too you think
you sleep but at that time they had high
Moon Studios
they had vicarious [ __ ] but anyway um
yeah I mean you know it's a different
it's a different day you know it's a
different day so and here's the thing if
they don't have enough surprises and
rewarding loop for the PvE guys this is
you guys you guys are gonna be miserable
and I'm saying for me dancing industry
for me this is amazing you know say like
I could just touch this love stuff okay
get to where I got to go and then BOOM
yeah I'm saying I'm into my trials and
my stuff for the weekend and stuff like
that so if this is a this is a dangerous
season
that could possibly be season of The
Drifter esque for you and we don't know
and that's the big thing but it knows
even talking with my chat and the
biggest thing is a first impression mmm
on a season of how long you're gonna
stick with it if somebody's like a
legend but on this season trials may not
be for me I gotta grind this new stuff
up
night falls which will get to the pile
that light level looks absolutely insane
I'm not yeah I'm somewhat casual this
stuff like thousand power level I get
like a few power love powerful gear
drops a week much less just trying to
get up to the powerful gear crap in
three month when it's yeah I was like
there Bungie is doomed
no matter who they try to make this game
for are we gonna make it for the rock or
are we gonna set the level so far out
there it's gonna be the crazy people to
get it well not everybody can play it
well hey everybody everything drops
really fast you don't have to grind that
hard everybody gets pinnacles from every
single thing that they do cool about the
top level well now the hardcore grinders
like what the hell am i playing this for
well I might have do in a raid cuz I get
the same thing from basic strike right
absolutely and then like hey you have
your pde hey it's like okay we got PvE
we got the all the stuff being built
we're gonna do this fractal line we get
the Sun Dial activities going on cool
where's my PVE pvp stuff we don't have a
whole lot of that going on trials is
coming cool alright well all my trials
people were really excited we're ready
to play trials and none of the other
side we turn down what do we got we got
you a public event with some talents
like this is like the extreme of what
some people may be thinking like I mean
trust me you put YouTube videos up
there's enough comments and be like blah
blah there's both sides of all this crap
um and it's just like PvP hasn't got a
lot of love for a while they're finally
getting the big deal of trials living
every weekend we'll talk about that
that is huge so hopefully it lands
that's kind of a question but
the trials is gonna be big they haven't
had a lot of PvP love we got three new
maps instead of like one may be all good
popular maps from d1 I don't care if
you're saying they're d1 maps they're
good maps that's fine
they're good Matthew's B yeah I played
them all about you not you know I played
them all they're out there good yes it
was so funny as soon as I jumped on some
of those maps I was like oh right here
in the memories yep I know this map oh I
didn't take those step nowhere it's like
nowhere to at least look I still suck
and get my butt whooped but at least I
know where to look on some maps I'm not
like learning a brand new one self yeah
I mean Mountain shot the Forte he said
you play on the content to level out
your character if you don't engage with
all the content you're gonna get left
behind
yeah I mean that's part of it but in
Annie's defense until the people you
know the PvE community you know I can
understand the concern and say hey is
it's gonna be what we doing you know
it's just only this now but what a comic
you don't want to comment real quick I
tried the legendary lost sector about
the Chi box dude it was just me and Chi
2 men 960 something we had no business
being in we were getting smashed right
but then we just started fighting and
going slow and you know if finally I
mean we got a zillion times but I had to
say it felt super rewarding doing
challenging content when you know we're
not supposed to be out I will say they
helped us out by not letting us go to
all of it it was a dick they keep you
there with them guests after that
wrestling with you both ah now I will
say when you were under level trying to
solo it was the first day I went in
there and I was like all right I tried I
really did knows like I was just playing
by myself waiting for people to get home
and it's like alright let me go see what
this lost sector is like made it through
the first basic guys it was the overload
captain by myself at level I couldn't do
it
I could not be that captain by myself I
could not do enough damage consistently
between reloading not dying him sneezing
at me the wrong way just like cuz then
if I lose like I can't pick you up you
can't kid me I'm with a group like
groups that's what I'm saying like my
cues usually in the chat like he was
saying 972 he was knocking out lost
sector he hit a group and like did some
LF geez and stuff like that and found
some people and I was like cool actually
does make people go to lfg s and play
together which is as you were saying
it's the struggle to get through which
is not a bad thing and I like that it's
not stupidly punishing if that makes
sense yeah yeah I was like it's a
thousand power level when you're like
970 Bill Garrett we got to work we got
to put up you know we got to put a
healing rifts and I got to put up my
barrier wallet now we can shoot through
the barrier barrier wall with the new
exotic and all these other things that
we've got going on it's like and we can
slowly work through this thing
coordinate fire ham I'm shooting the
auto rifle I've got him overloaded okay
let me reload real quick we're switching
back and forth those are cool times
mm-hmm and swords are beasts you are
correct Forte all sorts of beat bro yeah
that's what that was the key but a lost
sector because I think being me and CAI
struggle we do an all type of tricks
I got he's got his hunter he's got his
tether going I'm running stormcaller
you know I'm not okay shout out for them
to be an Evo
having servitors in the back with like a
whole gang of invincible bodyguards in
front
sniping yeah that's Eva that's you at
least being like a little all the way in
the back not trying to be see I'm like
yo and wit what's funny is we figured
that's over so we finally get through
that I'm like huh
brother tether you ready tether boom I'm
gonna coming in I'm gonna storm transom
out we're gonna get dominions so we
could we could narrow him down and then
like it was it was rough man we've ran
out of bullets a couple of times it was
hilarious
the funny thing is we redid it and
sinister was in this band all he did was
pull out that sword and that overload Oh
what's he curling the over lo bod he was
wrecking those things in seconds so
shout-out to the swords being really
cool
well yeah I got black talent calles
yesterday yes good going - but right now
I got my letter I got the UM B do the
the black armory sword that's got like
surrounded it's got it has got a cool
roll on it you know I'm saying so that's
the one I'm using and when I finally
started using so they felt good bad Oh
like if you're one the infinite looping
light attack animations JA Choon like oh
that feels good if you got like six like
if you got a bunch of people around
that's really cool and then on the other
side and you're like hey I've got this
big guy let me see how hard this heavy
attack kit hits and if it's full energy
man dude it is like you just uppercut
with like a guardian light energy it's
like I did a super uppercut leg it's
it's pretty beastly so no swords feel
lords feel pretty good this is where the
issue it's like exotic there's people in
chat are talking about world line zero
and Black Talon can't use the overload
catalyst on those or you can't use the
overload model notes and I'm like why
why I don't understand you have all
these exotics and you almost want us to
use like two primaries at times yeah
because you want like overload or you
want overload or anti barrier or
unstoppable which is only on hand
cannons and you're like okay so I need
barrier okay I need
I got auto rifles for overload if I'm
not running a sword like what are my
options here it's like they it's Lunden
sometimes they steer you back to almost
two primaries even though they're like
hey they've gotta do like if you want to
be able to cover and if you want to
cover it yourself like if I go into a
match made nightfall not the thousand
what what is it 917 L by going to one of
those and I don't trust anybody else
which you play enough rain to match
everyone's you're like I may be going in
with two sidearms which is what sadly
what I did but I'm gonna make sure you
can handle barrier and unstoppable would
it be there for everything yeah I was
like I'm gonna shoot peanuts but at
least my peanuts are gonna handle the
champion so hopefully you guys can do
some damage and I did that and I went
into as a nightmare hunt actually that I
did that's why I need it overload I
needed a hand cannon and a sidearm or
submachine gun and I was like submachine
gun hand Kanan and
whatever my heavy was I was just
breaking the champion says all my whole
purpose was like I'm back in double
premieres with a hand cannon and a
sidearm I'm like what just happened mmm
as a result they do you know you feel
there's some steering going on and
limiting you into these these these
lineup so to speak yeah cuz you've got
to be able to manage the champions most
of the time especially if you can't
mm-hmm breach light with vorpal I did
get that role oh yeah almost beast yeah
but yeah it's just one of those where
you are kind of oddly when you think
about handling the high content steered
away from like kinetic or like you know
kinetic special heavy you're like
kinetic energy primary and heavy and
you're like wait a minute how then
that's not work yeah mmm
it's just interesting it's just like
it's very sometimes it is just one of
those be like hey what about I can't use
the shotgun right now no no no damn it
and you just have those moments where
you want to go use that special weapons
slot and you really can't put it to use
on something but you're like hey and it
out put damage well if I don't have a
heavy weapon drop I'm gonna just be like
packing away at him for a while
so ya know I completely understand
completely and what you're saying is
valid you know I mean III definitely
hate your point we got a seat you gotta
see early early impressions though I get
the concern like I get it I trust me I
see what you have and then the other
side too is like what would be nice to
be like handy to handcannon cool let me
go grab Sun shot explode some heads go
put unstoppable on there I need it for
whatever mod I'm facing but at least I
can blow up some faces and see some cool
explosions while I have to 80s for a
second get my and stop a brown stop that
giant ogre but at least I can blow some
stuff up while I do like same thing
Kravitz on Lance would be fun vigilant
swing or a pulse like haven't used that
with an exotic and I've thought about
that multiple times but a lot of those
energy exotics especially because Sun
shot Kravitz on Lance they have some
cool effects to him and you know I just
started using so sure I just got the
catalyst ah somebody actually told me
they got theirs this week too yeah so
catalysts are now dropping in the wild
like they are dropping in the strikes
got that and the luminol one put on ice
all right let me just officer shot just
to get it ready I had no idea this such
that was doing what it's doing explode
like and it's not a headshot just if
they die and they turn into us bomb just
cut all the time yeah snappy powerful
like you know and it I was I was I was
digging it I was think that's my cell
you don't let me get this this cattle is
done but um yeah I got a see were three
seasons in I know we're not the only
ones there to be like hey can we throw
mobs on exotics and they still won't let
us do it and I'm just like
I just balance cowboy you know we don't
look too crazy oh it's not we talked
about this [ __ ]
the only haul if do you think the weapon
itself is balanced if you don't if
there's not a giant sandbox batch hatch
to changing maysun shots too powerful it
got left alone it must be pretty good
right now okay
now let me just use that to break the
champion shield everything else I use it
for is normal so it's like it's not
gonna break the game I just would love
to use some of them because we have
these collections of weapons and if you
go into the champion type content not
gonna use them it's just weird though
I would like I would really like to see
those I don't expect them in season 11
just the next one but in year 4 and come
on give me give me that mod slot on the
exotics please all their exotics the
ones that you want to keep around for so
long but what's the point of men but you
can't play what exactly's because they
don't got a little mud on it what are we
doing okay but if you need those
champions if you're going in to talk to
your content I'm not saying just like
hey I'm gonna go run a basic strike yeah
I can blow it Sun shot and blow up heads
you can do that with like a dragon fly
weapon too like yeah but if you want hey
I want to go in the top content solar
would be good in this situation I've got
Sun shot I can slap it on now I need I
need a hand cannon unstoppable barrier
situation cool I'm gonna throw that on
Sun shot cuz it is the hand cannon why
not
I don't it sounds fun but what would
happen most likely people will get
locked in to two guns that are just the
most effective way going forward and you
know how they feel about us liking stuff
too hard and not utilizing the rest of
their arsenal they don't like it
the able to use everybody this season is
gonna be running that auto rifle once
they get it though that's the only one
that seems like it's worth it him yeah I
was like the Seraph weapons aren't crap
because the war mine sells seem pretty
cool but it's gonna be that auto rifle
that is running everything so it's like
mm-hmm they're like all over they want
us liking it too long they just want us
to like what they want us to like Oh
daddy Bungie I've been telling them
that's how daddy Bungie does it's about
they want you like what they like and
their whole thing is balance and it's
it's all all you know we want this whole
they want to do this whole melting pot
hey try our wares try our swords try a
good a legit exotics that have this on
them oh you need on a stoppable go grab
that side I'm with that laser beam well
I've got I've got other options no just
this one that look is it's a you need to
change you need to break barriers mmm
what about all these other got exotic
you know auto rifles for breaking
barriers no we're not gonna let you sir
oh so we're not gonna let you use
hardlight you gotta go grab Ariana's Val
if you want to break me so like there
are exotics that do those yeah the big
boats unstoppable as well there are
exotics they do those so they have that
ability on exotics already
so why not put a why not allow it in
their seasonal rotation they've
literally I'd like that that's your
that's your that's your RNA like oh now
you're talking I don't cook it down I
know that's fine that one up
no no no - are you got that again that's
- that was very good sir I like that
no you're right like I thought that was
the route they were gonna go right I
thought you know okay they've got this
new let's be Robin I like unstoppable
champions I like overload I like that
mechanic in our content it feels
different yo we got to knock that shield
down he go get his health back cuz let's
be real destiny vets we're gonna blaze
through this stuff we know all the trip
eat you out here so who in contact they
gotta put a stop to you you are you are
you are you're dangerous for that like
the you in the other robot what's our
robot friend on human friend that we
like Oh
esoteric schmuck no you you you I mean
he's a beast he's a beast for sure you
know saying but you get busy but man get
busy too so at the end of the day you
don't say fix your face at the end of
the day The Dig is you know they want to
make things difficult they want to give
us a challenge I love that aspect but I
thought they were going to go to La Vie
at this breath route right what your
call is gonna be unstoppable is a
intrinsic per Ariana's Val you know one
of those other joints is a intrinsic
perk right I thought the do exotics may
have that flavor to try to encourage
utilizing to do one and it seems like
since shadow keep going away from that
like Dave
they don't want I think maybe as an
experiment and they like we don't like
it and we're not putting this on exotics
anymore and it is an interesting change
in in philosophy so yeah they definitely
backtracked I agree with you they
definitely they introduced something
that I thought that was gonna be the new
wave now and no you know I mean so it
comes down to utilizing these these
legendaries and you know it's it's
basically each season is what is the
flavor legendary of the you know of them
off now I'm saying now it's like okay
Scouts are not cool
now for you know imposes not cool right
now for anti barrier so now it's this
and now it's that yeah it is the is the
season of go shake hands with the enemy
up close and personal you get a you
gotta be with what rain you want it what
you want it well you get you you want to
get busy you you wonder you didn't want
to get pushed back remember years like
you wanna you wanna be in a mix so now
you the mix yeah but you sign it up
master my bosses but lease you can kill
them down more damage but you're still
gonna get smashed away you might get one
swipe in and then your king to cross the
map if you don't die into a wall well if
you use your stun mechanic with your uh
overload boss oh well not a boss back so
that's the stops you still have to kill
bosses and you might go through a
legendary loss sector and there might be
champion so that you can break the
champion P so much if you get to a boss
and you're like hey let me go put some
sort into bus then you go flying away
from this giant stomping guy yeah you're
still getting done but I see your point
you know III would be surprised if we
ever get there
acting I think it's not something
they're interested in doing all right
no I got to continue this level
discussion and I wanted to see your
thoughts or if you checked around the
dresser Grand Master nightfall review
load out build I'm not that's not even
the right words modifiers and light
level did you look at what that thing's
gonna be I did nap but I saw your text
messages get into it okay
so if you guys haven't actually just
browse through the director and being
like hey night falls
hey grandmasters not out yet that's fine
but let me click on it oh my god
so grand master nightfall
1060 power level
yeah what do we have right now 970 died
70 now it's gonna come out in six weeks
so you got some time to get to the
powerful cap yeah yeah at that time they
are going to open up some more pinnacle
drops as well those are gonna be your
basic challenges from Zavala drifter or
weekly clan that's tough so there will
be options for more pinnacle drops as
opposed to your dungeons in just your
raids like trials will have some - we
got that going on
Pinnacle's are still going to take you
to a thousand ten mm-hmm now what's the
highest you've ever had your artifact
bonus power level plus what
I know just plus like plus o plus I'd
plus
a thumpin I don't know 50 what was your
15 in 20
yeah so if you got this you got to
season or Inc like 207 I think I've
heard that's plus money that gets you
that bonus
hmm so if say you do get 20 plus power
levels which if we don't have double exp
at a seasonal event if we don't have
time loss bounties I wouldn't have even
getting been close they're 21 22 and
late depends on how much you play that's
still a crapload of bounties
oh you're potentially average person
probably gonna say 15 feels about where
you get to if you play a decent amount
you don't over kill the season but I
played a pretty good amount but I'm not
like streaming and limit in the game
right so 15 to 20 that means I'm gonna
be a thousand 25 to a thousand thirty at
the absolute max if I maxed out
pinnacles right Grandmaster nightfall
60 so for the average person it's 45
power levels probably above you mm-hmm
and you have every modifier that was on
master plus about four more you have
limited revives hmm you have extra
shields you have they had to make
something a little bubble called prime
modifiers and they shoved about five
more in there there's no there's no
joining in progress extinguishes on
there they've got extra champions upon
extra champions there's more shields on
enemies like shanks have solar shields
like just random stuff the wouldn't have
shields there's a limited number of
revives so if you are struggle bus in in
there you can't just like hang in a
corner rez and die and like gets a
little peak shots so I was just curious
your thoughts on that one just it like
to think I I mean I know like okay so
the people who play 12 hours a day and
the ones who are gods here like gigs who
was a thousand ten before trials even
starts those are the ones like but they
got through the powerful and the
pinnacles that artifact is nothing but
time yes so even if you're a thousand 25
and you're looking at 45 power levels
dado in a group is probably gonna get a
group of his height to other people
together they're gonna fight through it
but in a stay on they're gonna fight
through it and they will probably do it
I will definitely say they will they
will do it like esoterics gonna have a
couple of people
if you solos a Grand Master I'm going to
just like oh you know it's coming oh
that is gonna be insane but I'm sure it
will either way you are talking about a
fraction of a tiny of 1%
so yeah that's so probably I was gonna
say it's like is that who you wanted
that alert is the light level out there
too far is that but again the question
time did you see the rewards
I did not ascendant shards are coming
and exotics Armour is coming that is the
only two things listed on there okay and
I like that now that you're that
makeshift me a little bit yeah I don't
want the other yeah and I ain't about
that reward like dad that's not
incentive enough for those guys you know
what I was going to say right are you
dropping that bombshell was that you
know this is for that one percent you
know deed the guys that are making you
know and I'm not gonna throw my man
under the bus but he did put this out
shut up to glad
you know he was like yeah you know I saw
the tweets he was like hey you know um I
don't feel it it's for me right now you
know where this has put me you know I'm
saying I shouted that's alighieri a good
good friend of the room you know I'm not
happy you know there's nothing
challenging for me these are the
sentiments that just a few weeks ago
dudes were jumpin or stream they were
very upset about chance now challenge
you're facing this throw your face all
in this and now I don't want to hear now
I will say like and then why do you
challenge yourself like that to your
point those awards need to be better for
those guys right those who work for that
1% that 5% those rewards like thankfully
though if I hated Berta home yeah like
you know for that five you you gotta now
bless them
you know I'm saying that is not an easy
feat you know and all these negative
modifies all these things that you put
in you know yeah is going to twelve yet
instead of eight now it's twelve things
against you it's 12 yeah dad that's
gonna discourage a lot of people that's
gonna discourage you don't mean I'm not
that's not I'm not living that type of
life like that's not a life I want to
know how you don't shout out to anyone
who's doing it you know me I will be
staying far away from that now if you
would have said you know there's some
rare exotic or you know there's
something that you get a quest line to
start something absolutely now I'm now
alright you know what that's a goal to
strive for that's something you know I
can
can get behind but they still not there
with you know I like the idea of
nightfall or deal right I like the idea
of that but they're still not there with
rewards on that kind of stuff you got
yeah like we still need we still need
more we still need those exclusive I
mean they did put those in you know
having exclusive stuff that's right but
I guess that would debuted when we
before we have random roles and a lot of
stuff you know they got a reward we work
the reward system for Pinnacle content
that still been their Achilles heel
indeed - - a couple of hero moments with
whisperer and you know I'm saying all
that zero hour but for the most part the
day to day stuff rating comp right the
pinnacle rewards haven't been you know
and even um you know we talked about you
know what Peter Harris II wish ender and
also like it just it needs to be better
it needs to be you know really dominate
those guys got a got a shot I think the
closest they came was probably 1k but
then they kind of it's so random and so
rare that it's like you know so that's
where I'm at it is they got they still
got work to do that's what about with
them I just yeah I was like I was just
trying to throw it out there cuz I
literally logged in as like on I post oh
let me look oh oh oh God like it was
just the reaction of just like oh just
to know what it's gonna take to get
through that and you think about laying
limited revive so we're talking about
like raid tokens I'm like maybe the idea
how many people I watch as a group like
die or hide in a corner or find a place
to go I was like those are those are
gonna be punishing and it's like and I
know certain people are gonna do it and
that's that's what they made it for but
it's like as you said if you make it so
so difficult and out of the reach of
most people you got to make a reason and
then presscon set it to it's like I need
a reaiiy still need a reason to
masterwork armour to make the golf balls
feel worth their pain like to go even a
master nightfall is gonna be 10:30 with
like eight modifiers going on I still
need a reason to go reach even outside
of my level to go get a golf ball it's
like they are those the reason to play
the content or it's like mastering the
the armor like getting from seven to ten
maybe giving one more scavenger mod or
one more little ma is that the one that
makes that content better or is there
other ways that they need to be
considering how to handle it though yeah
no no I I agree I think I said this is
they've still got a tweak they've still
gotta find their way with this and um
you know make no mistake this is
definitely you know the hardcore you
asked for it you gonna get it but they
still got this which they don't have the
reward balance yet for the level of
investment commitment that's always
gonna be a problem yeah I mean black
wings are sitting there saying in chat
and this may be extreme but it's like if
you had a hard mode raid and a
grandmaster nightfall I mean he said
grandmaster armor that comes with 4 bit
4 mod slots 70 plus stats and should be
full exotic armor so I'm like and you
can even either get like an extra perk
that you can wear or some way to set
that apart with like ultra stat rules so
if you do spend your time and you get
armor drops in there right that it's
actually getting to be like okay like
you're sitting out like 70 stats but my
god if you put time into those insane
activities in but then you actually feel
like hey I've got extra mod [ __ ] they
hold 12 or 13 energy so you can hold
another mod like all of that type of
stumbling that's the level that that
type of content should be doing because
currently
the armor is
[Music]
making that much of a difference I would
say it's not like I'm leveling up a huge
deal if I go do this stuff I'm just like
I'm my power level goes up but the armor
I get doesn't change that much it
changes recharge times but I'm like I'm
not stronger with resilient longer yeah
yeah I'm not faster I'm not
I can i still i've always joked like you
could be stronger and have more health
with resilience you could be faster with
mobility I still never know never know
what to do with recovery in like an RPG
sense those wheels that to me and then
of course recharge times will recharge
times but those types of things are
where maybe year for could stretch
towards but as you said like hard mode
raids or crazy night falls or trials
like and you have your kind of trifecta
and then maybe gambit perfected if that
ever exists but mmhmm right well I agree
that that that would be an awesome
cadence I agree I think that would be
something they really need to do they've
got to they've got to make some
adjustments there's there's no doubt
speaking of rewards by the way mm-hmm
you see all those possible seasonal
rewards that we've got from Zavala
we've got from Jax got from drifter yeah
no I mean nevermind we don't have ritual
sees that we have to talk about that man
we gotta talk about it man like look
there's a lot of this to controversies
going on that I know one was the emblem
stuff you know say me lightly touch and
I definitely understand the sentiment
you know I'm not a big emblem guy but if
I put thousands and thousands of hours
into something if I get yeah don't yeah
yeah don't do it and they made the
statement and you know that you know you
know what's going on now but that's a
big that's a big blow to wake up that's
almost jarring right if you care if
you're the type of destiny play that
kids a lot about that that's a sense of
priority now with this thing
yeah I was surprised to see you know I
just looked at all the vendors like
bless the iron banner bow you've got
that
that's not it chief and I've got a bit
it's disrespectful for me even say that
cuz I see it but come on like but III
just I just don't like them not telling
us that's what I have issues with but
when you don't say anything right and
you wake up and you emblems are gone and
there's no ritual weapons people gonna
feel away they gonna feel away and it's
it to me it's like what's the purpose of
doing those activities then because
outside of the powerful gear war and its
season you'll be able to get pinnacles
well I mean you will be able to strikes
gambit Cruz crucible you're gonna have
those pitiful drops coming weekly from
the waitress but I'm talking about the
ritual weapon oh I know right now that
I'm literally know the other side of
what maybe they could be thinking
they need to do something about the
ritual because I thought this was the
new thing they they told us no Pinnacle
weapon right it's too much was too hard
to benefit there with many exotics well
okay fine
alright now you're saying this ritual
weapon they came one season but a much
more underwhelming but at least people
were like alright there's something to
chase in nice in these mo
something to chase there's a carrot
there alright it's better than what the
knife was offered it says it is a unique
thing I get it but to not say that is a
problem you know saying that's a problem
and I just worry I know they got trials
in the back pocket that that should do
well for them we'll get into that but I
just worry that you know what is there
really you you need things to inspire
aspire for that's just how destiny works
you know it's just that this is this is
a bad luck yeah this is a bad look I
can't I can't sugarcoat it yeah I was
very surprised they did that and did did
anybody make a statement as to did they
respond to anyone saying that's what
asked you so how come people like hey is
it me like no rituals know that my body
for Bungie said I saw nil and basically
put out that we're looking we're taking
in feedback from the first couple days
of the season over one of the bullet
points ritual weapons engrams like her
emblems like those were like to talk to
so right yeah it's I mean they they got
the feedback but they can't obviously
change it this season it's not victory
improvement rituals halfway through or
stuff that's not that's not happening so
and that stuff they said they would
discuss later but even in the 12 you
know there's certain things that they
know that like right here in the top of
the swab we were seeing discussion on
new weapons of the season because people
are thinking the perks are pretty weak
mmm the Purple's are fairly limited
mmm the war mine cells are beefy but
that's a different animal mm-hm
lack of ritual weapons for Vanguard
crucible emblems I mean that stuff
they're like Heyward taking in the
feedback but
again that's all we know is like we're
hearing it we don't know what's gonna
happen about it not just gonna be like
hey we miss virtual weapons we're gonna
make sure we get them in a season four
done no it's gonna be hey we get it in
we're gonna get a director's cut from
Lou Smith we really can't make these
things happen
or if we do they're just like check box
they don't get a lot of Hughes like but
it's there's a lot of development time
we don't have any reasons yet right now
which is again I don't know
yeah I mean it's just you know they've
got to do something you know saying
they've got they're sitting on stuff and
it's just like I don't understand the
thought process of not communicating
with this and um yeah man this is this
is this is a bad look this is this is
really a bad look and I was very
disappointed to see you know those type
of weapons there and the last point I'll
make with this and we move on from this
one is that I get on a PvP side you know
what's the reason to one run comp this
year
right I'm like wow that is a good
question
you know because again trials is here
that's the new new the hot Ferrari is
back now right everybody's going to
trials so God not having any you know
weapon and I'm saying like and then
let's be real since y'all ever said shot
a weapon retirement gang
you don't saying it ain't gonna be much
longer we gonna be we saw those numbers
we woke up to at the end of every weapon
you know as far as you know this can't
be infused past this level apparently
that's all am i tweet about that was
apparently it's been there just don't
notice the number but either way at some
point you're gonna be like hard capped
at that so then that's a sample at some
point so that all of those will go yeah
is that right now I what's the incentive
to do comp like I don't I don't see it
you know if that day and then again you
take away you know most likely the
future provoker and all this other stuff
and you know um you know what you cause
it foreclosed and right you know regex
or whatever you know they've got a lot
of answers to provide to the community
and reference to the thought process
here
did not like that at all that'll be
Alice
so mm-hmm it's like first day we've got
public event mm-hmm warmind bit grinding
encrypted warmind bits for the chest
mm-hm we've got upgrading the bunkers in
pcs you got the bonuses to come from
those I'm in used all of them yet like
haven't actually seen the big warframe
but we'll say yeah
just like first three days the initial
impression because trials launches after
we get done with this podcast so many of
you guys who listened to this see it
later on YouTube
trials is gonna launch like in three
hours so obviously we'll have a take on
it next weekend mmm but we're gonna do a
little pre chat about it but before we
just get into talking about trials I
wanted to get just like the first three
days initial overall walk in the door
feel the impressions
again honeymoon stage so it felt decent
for me I did like the challenge of
certain activities but because I was
under levelled namely lost sector was a
high point for me you know I really
loved that challenge I love that aspect
of those guys running around in their
you know their the Overlord I you know
say it unstuck I love that stuff so I
join it um
I will say this story beats were cool
you ever says far as least have a little
cinematics them there you know being
more invested than just a game giving
you an opening sent about and then just
throwing you in the mix there was still
little steps you know I'm saying it was
I stayed talking around speeding it was
uh you know I'm saying it was Anna and
what you call it you know I'm saying and
it's of Allah and their banter you know
again little nuances that I like but um
initially look and I'm not blown away
you know saying it's right now some
serviceable content to grind service
will be light right now but like contact
right now to grind until we get the full
what's behind the curtain
right they claim the dish stuff behind
the curtain they're playing the stuff
that they're working on we got to see
and we got to see but right now
initially
see I can't even answer cuz I'm so
biased with trials you don't say so it's
like it's tough for me because for me
the PvP happened you know my PvP side is
in heaven you know in a few hours I'm
about to go crazy he does it and so but
I get it yeah and that's good I was like
and that's why I think next week's
discussion will be interesting now yes
power levels gonna be in effect this
weekend we know that it's gonna be
skewed for some people the crazy
hardcore at a thousand twelve or
whatever I've seen ten thousand twelve
up there for sure yes um so for the
average person walking into trials this
weekend here's this new activity first
time they've tried it I am NOT a I'm not
a streamer grinder I actually have a day
job i leveled some I'm like 975 how do
you think it's gonna go for the average
security average yeah that was what
lighter weight average player light
level like what lovely I'm 977 you're
975 I like be effort about the average
light level for those going into shrine
trials yeah baby day 960 boots Oh trust
me I think I think it's gonna be more on
the low end that should be and I think
because let's be real like we a lot of
us even us who know the deal and note
about you got a great video out by the
way they were saying like we know the
grind it's just a matter of the time
investment right so those with the time
investment the hawk or to me they
represent such a small percentage you
know that hopefully we don't encounter
as much as them as we think but um I
think it's gonna be more in the low end
I don't think only the the hard court is
going you go see them them them 10 to 10
ATT ID numbers when you jump inside does
address you know it's gonna it's gonna
be it's gonna be interested um I don't I
want to know also how they're scaling is
it is it strictly you know iron banner
style and I'm saying as far as the you
know that is concerned we got a see man
I mean I'm not gonna go crazy about it
but I guess is that it will be toward
the low the lower end maybe average
probably you know we're where we are you
know I'm saying like even a nine low
under nine eighty tonight you know nine
seventy that's a guy putting a little
decent ground for two three days but two
days you don't say are strong grinding
yeah and then um you know there are
these other guys definitely gonna be
I hate there's no doubt but that again
it's one week and then next week they
supposedly implement whatever but what
do you think like where you where you
add things what I might try it like but
Monday if I get to squeak sometime in or
a little bit like that and if I can find
some people to play with you and start
Bart but
if you get if you even got on kind of a
roll and then all of a sudden you go
into a match be like dude I'm getting
light I cannot my shots aren't hitting
this hard I'm getting smoked over here
and then you check that guys like
profile like halfway through a match be
like hey I got killed let me check out
and playing against holy crap that guy's
like a thousand fifteen light level and
I'm like nine eighty over here you got a
twenty five point advantage on me damn
like mm-hmm
I hope they everyone
they make it ultra obvious in-game like
the little pop-ups they do that not like
you accidentally look at wrong and it
goes away you need to like acknowledge
and click ok trials this weekend has
power enabled next weekend this will not
be there so this is kind of an
experience I want them to make for the
average person cuz like even the fact
that we were in the tuam we follow their
twitter we're like on top of what's here
there's a lot of people who don't even
want you youtube videos to know this
crap is coming they're just gonna be
like hey trials hey I got two friends
you want to play it cool uh we just
gotta ask it like I mean and just for
those people so they don't be like what
the hell this this is dumb late so that
isn't a thing this is where like the
little in-game tutorials not the little
flying tooltips that pop up by the way
two tips though shout out today about
really being effective or PC cuz you
loaded too fast to read to do that's
perfect or you don't know say you can
say but yeah it's like some people could
have that rut this is again the first
impressions of the season is where I've
worried about this season first
impression you log and be like hey it's
a new currency it's a novelist grind
there's like two weapons and there's
just this public event I can't even go
to the lost sector
I don't know how much I'm gonna put in
the season a couple bodies let me go -
let me go play trials
I'm not saying me I'm saying this is
like someone these knees can't believe
just they're like hey the log-in person
who plays for a couple nights who
doesn't read Twitter and watch YouTube
videos he's like hey I'm just gonna get
my destiny this weekend mmm yes that's
my worry I'm gonna play mmm you know me
I'm gonna play some or another I'm still
gonna try my trials if I can get some
but I'm good great but for some people
and I'm wondering about you know st.
half of the bases on this old for casual
not in the north side how does it feel
for them and that's where I've tried to
kind of put myself this dislike these
few days to look at some things and be
like they're gonna launch Grand Master
nightfall
that's not for some people it's enough
for a lot not for a lot of people areas
yeah we got to try for sure then you've
got trials if they have that first time
bad experience or they see what they're
facing they may not get into that so
it's like I I worry about this feels
like a drifter season begin the spring
season but it's like how many how many
are gonna be like I've literally had
some people be like hey I haven't played
since drifter if this is a falling off
point and they're like hey I'm coming
back I'm like well you got a lot of
stuff food now could be cool a grain you
know get sassy season of dawn you're
gonna get to see season of a dying
shadow keep us their opulence to school
they're not relevant anymore shadow keep
is but yeah but it's just like I I worry
about the fall-off of some people yeah
and it's again the persistence of yeah
I'm gonna go try the thousand nightfall
and I'm like I'm in there I'm like I'm
trying I'm throwing the nightfall at him
I didn't have the sword yet so that
would be a thing to try later forced
elope but those are pieces for I'm like
alright I will try and I'm little
slightly weird one some people just
won't and yes I've been whoa yeah it's
like this is where it's kind of gonna be
this will be an interesting thing to
watch like if you could watch like
player numbers and stuff like that like
see where it starts at the top of season
kind of check like 1 week 2 week 3 weeks
4 weeks and then like after a month in
too much
I checked those ranks and see what the
numbers do to see if this is one of
those that doesn't hit or if it's like
learn out on like the bit grind or
whatever it's like this is just where
I'm kind of curious where things start
landing no no yeah it's a good question
I my gut tells me it's gonna be a
majority more majority of lower to
middle you know I'm saying in that as
opposed to the hard core you know so I
think I think it's gonna be hell can
says if I log in and play trials and I
see gigs on the other team I'm just
gonna take a screenshot send it to you
and then put one of me walking out the
door I'm just gonna sit I'm gonna do it
emote sit down and just be like yep I'm
here I'm not doing anything don't be
funny you're funny look man it is I
think I think a lot of people are going
to give it a shot just a bit the whole
magic behind it being back and people
are gonna test to see how far they come
and put their skill out there doctor
stuff do they got a shot to deliver Lucy
so when it comes we do know a little bit
more details there's actually trials
paid vertical requires 960 plus the
trials passage which I guess you have to
do that quest for hmm and pre-made fire
team starts Friday ends Tuesday so it is
on the circle not Monday which yes and
we're thinking the weekend but it's
scheduled
so a couple more things that we know
don't know what the quest is gonna be
like that is the first step
mmm you can go talk to the saint and get
the quest going but right guys you can't
finish that one yet it's just like you
kind of kick it off right yeah it'd be
kind of be curious how long it takes
practically be like sitting at Saint
Anne be like all right what's next step
are we just going in what do we got to
do because they say free tall players
but they said there's gonna be a quest
involve is it like go get one kill in
PvP or go do this that the other so it's
like
the longer steps we're hoping to keep
the cheaters and the free people out
though right Brian I mean they could
they could take an approach how they
used to do but over my favorite brownie
from d1 was it the true meaning of war
bounty that shacks used to have and he'd
put you through a series of tests it was
long you know and it's different weapon
types of stuff like that so they got
some things that opportunity to go play
come to go let's riles hahaha
you know what's funny they would
probably do that you know we laughing
they would probably do that cuz they
know damn well that is it oh I remember
some real quick you asked me some other
stuff that I did like about um so far
with the PvE content I actually like
that the warmind bounties give you the
option to play crucibles I do buy a
pallet one or the other you notice
there's not a third combo with gambit
out there yes yes you've got black
Horbury yeah they got one is a forge of
black armory where they'll play over
match your humble rail it's quicker you
know hey there we go we're gonna play
classic mix go play this I like that and
then even in there they like yo if you
use a linear fuse you know if you do use
a fusion for whatever it is you know
what type of weapon type specifically
we're gonna give you bonus I like that
that's so philosophy wise I liked it but
back to the literally that's a good one
because that is yeah that's a nice piece
for those who don't want to live in PV
it's like hey I do wanna grind this up
but I want to go play a PvP do both mmm
completely
so Rawls next thing we know we finally
have an idea because every does one are
there boons how is this gonna work how's
the card so we know it's seven wins
right and there are five unique passages
that can be bought from Saint which
offer their own mechanics each passage
will track wins and losses losses in a
single trials run if three losses appear
on a passage players will be restricted
from the activity and have to either
reset the passage or purchase a new one
hmm
doh we've got always available mercy
forgives one loss per run
seven wins not nine right right the
other side you have ferocity with the Z
with zero losses your third win grants a
bonus win mm-hmm if you get one through
three you really just have four hmm
so those are the two that are always
available and then these are the ones
that unlock after you do specific things
there is after five wins you unlock
increased trials tokens from completing
and winning trials matches yes at seven
wins grants bonus XP from trials scaling
with the number of wins on a ticket
mm-hmm bless you my wife walked in
Anstey's a Ludo perfect timing
yeah absolute uh shout-out to shadow to
my wife she's awesome and then finally
after going flawless confidence variance
a bonus reward from the flawless jest so
you got to go flawless once and then you
can get the confidence run if you do it
again then you can get a bonus run our
bonus right reward we're so thoughts on
those since we finally have some details
since they weren't even in the swab it's
just the whole art of momentum yeah just
to me there's all this stuff just like a
slight rework like I don't I don't feel
like anything is dramatically different
I think they wanted to eliminate the
whole thing from d1 where people were
just sitting on this plethora of trials
tokens and stuff like that you're not
I'm saying and um you know I think they
want to avoid that you got that whole
you know they kind of depreciate or okay
limonade it I guess after it's it's done
as far as the UM the weekend or whatever
or technically they go away right so is
that gonna be no hoard it no hoarding
going on that kind of thing but um yeah
to me this is just a real but the key
right now like I said that's rumor the
room yeah yeah gobble Bercy so I was
happy about that's happy about the
mercies like the key right now is gonna
be the ones we've nailed the aesthetic
we've nailed the armor we got our
Egyptian pharaoh gods I could look like
a moon rock I'm very happy you know I'm
saying got my new best joint going on
and and now it's just more of okay these
weapons I want that separation I want
that adept but the people that go to you
know to the lighthouse you know or maybe
some new in transit perk that you know
is trial specific and um it would be
really cool for them to take advantage
of that that that's what I was you know
but
yeah I'm hyper I don't think it's
Oh can we talk about the elephant in the
room that really surprised me
oh and your yeah yeah well we're really
surprised he said you kid a glow cheese
guy yeah I like my clothes I like the
smell it
I like the glow van glow look nice yours
this I'm trying to go for that
definitely a set up on that but to me
the biggest thing the day did to get all
the announcements to get all the
trailers as fiery as that is if you
remember I think it was yesterday I had
tweeted you at a you slow mo forte and
screen and it blew me away when I was on
Reddit and they had that announcement in
reference to the whole you know
the Dawson network connectivity you know
I'm saying this is a huge deal
I'm saying we all know severity and I
felt strongly they would do something I
didn't know they were going this heart
well apparently from what I'm told they
are hiding your IP address you're not
saying that you can't you cannot get
DDoS now does this make you immune from
every single type of hacker cheater no
but that's a big one
that's a big one you know I'm saying so
it's eliminate off the table is a huge
deal you know I'm saying so hopefully
they continue and they can monitor and I
like that you know cuz technically this
was a steam move my understanding you
know say only bungees worthless team to
make sure it's like it's working that
way but yeah it's like they're hiding
they're using steam packet IDs as
opposed to like literally your IP
address so right now yeah it's
definitely got some security stuff in
the 12 as well we'll get to but mmm they
they did make a shift though it's
definitely and it was weird that they
made a shift but like reddit knew it
like two days before they place in
Judaism yeah I'm just like hey let me
try a DDoS I hear DDoS let's see what's
dy mmm yeah as more the rewards have you
looked at what weapons potentially will
be available I I skimmed I skimmed an
omni are you trying to stay dark yeah I
know I I was like oh here's like man who
would break down every soil each story
spoilers gonna be like why don't I don't
want to know all the rewards yet for
this trials thing because I want to go
in and be really I want to have my
moment out there and it's just gonna be
wonderful
[Laughter]
how much cuz I was peeking right now I
do I always shout the fourth day they
were telling me you know my thing was
Diablo uh you know that I did I'm happy
I'm a happy camper but um as far as DB
weapons and stuff like that you know
they're definitely some stuff that I see
that I'm like oh yeah remember that I
remember this one you know uh my
understanding there's one I know that
it's not in here that people were
thinking
900 rpm or does not appear to be in the
list the doctrine season may be another
season bill right now your primary if I
recall primaries their autos and Scout
our cool
they are yeah I think I think that they
are going to do doctrine in the sec
because I don't the doctrine debuted in
season one trials in d1 Chad knows
correct me if I'm wrong but my gut is
telling me
it didn't and that's when they switched
to a different format of web because I
remember like the charge levels were
like how they gone down they were kind
of like black with the yel dig and I
remember when doctor came out they were
kind of like it was different this thing
it was a difference scheme but I could
be wrong I could be wrong I think it did
debut with the first set of weapons I
think they saved it but that next set
and you know fine like I said I just
want to see the weapons I want to you
know get get ahold of that and then see
what other rewards they do you know for
that lighthouse run but super pump man
super like your armor at least if you
get armor this season it doesn't seem to
instantly be trash in the stat
Department - so I will say a lot more
legendary as you look at him you're like
hey I'm in the mid-50s they don't just
told you to suck I got one I don't like
my highest one I might have had one at
60 I don't think I did
maybe 58 or 59 but like more frequent
not just like hey I need iron banner to
get anything to consider just legendary
czar I mean you look at them all oh yeah
there's no ghost there's a nice-looking
Sparrow so those will be out there I'm
sure for crazy rewards but yeah yes
armor and stuff is definitely there so
[Music]
hang go back to that page so we got the
boons they passages can be used
throughout a trials week even can be
reset at any time
only one passage can be purchased so I
think they said it's actually gonna sit
in your quest tab you're just gonna be
resetting it that way trials bounties
well now the bounties and rewards are
kind of different because the bounty is
actually I thought gave you the rewards
previously like if you go through and
you got that three wins that's your
bounty check now the bounties are like
your weeklies your dailies and your
additionals you can have you know rate
points and tokens and all those types of
things so they're saying
weekly bounties are going to be 35 valor
rank points and five trials tokens daily
bounties and 15 Valor inks and two
trails tokens and additionals will be
two trials tokens so all about those
trials tokens which would be able to go
to saint or teen turn in some packages
for right rewards players with 3 5 or 7
wins on the trash passes will be granted
a weekly challenge trials award based on
those which can unlock on a single
passage once 3 losses appear in a
passage wins will no longer so three
wins powerful geared tier 1
those who are level 1010 this is now
gonna be helping them very much
five wins powerful here Tier three
that's a pretty big leap actually for
like the plus five that's five wins and
then seven wins
whether it's flawless or not if you do
manage seven wins that's here that's a
pinnacle drop yeah so you're getting
your pinnacles in your pinnacles which I
like to like finally get DVP a big deal
going flawless on a trails passage will
grant players access to the light a
reward space available only to players
with a flawless passage players will get
access to pinnacle gear from the
flawless chest no pinnacle for seven
sounds like pinnacle flawless
this clinical gear will be given once
per week per class once the chest has
been open and players leave the
lighthouse a new flawless message will
need to be completed to return so do you
think it's seven now it says seven wins
on the rewards for pinnacle but then
there say going flawless is also
pinnacles do you think there's too
I think I think it's one okay I didn't
honestly know which way to read that
yeah I think it's one I think it's all
uncompensated I think I think it's um
yeah bandy this is this all you were
hoping for
let's call Bonnie's got rewards I'm its
euphoric right now but like deep like I
said he's just really doing it and um
the only thing I said I would hope for I
know this is long so I probably not
gonna happen
I was hoping for like a trials the
trials trials exactly I mean to be
asking too much yeah yes how's medically
neurotics does that help you
I guess flawless to get exotic talk
about making people lose their mind even
Abel is they be an exotic but I need the
carrier but there ddossing me but now I
can't details but their auto they're
inviting me like man there would be
sister yeah I'd be I wouldn't mind one
start by getting say hey you need 50
wins and trials however you gain they're
like a good chunk spend some time in the
playlist you may not you could get it
this first weekend if you play a lot or
if you play a little bit you give a
group like every softened through the
season that type of thing I could see
and then do another stuff but like if
it's a flawless trials exotic yeah that
V they said be let it be limited if we
live but it be something stifle
[Laughter]
Grandmaster nightfalls better have some
type of situation going on there too if
you get one we get absolutely absolutely
you know that the final trials gear or
won any trials tokens you have spin them
before the weekend before we clear said
cuz they go away yes you do not carry
them over and they said trials gear
glows players who go flawless each week
we'll have the trials gear equipped will
have a yellow glow that will appear
fading slowly after fading slowly after
one week that'll be interesting only is
it Tuesday's that kind of there's
Thursday it's almost gone Friday it's
back get back to normal
fresh players will need to go flawless
again once a player goes close they will
receive two unique trials emblems I can
further change their color their glow
color light for the lost trials glow
turns white when equipped light makers
wear this emblem when carrying other
players to the lighthouse
Wallace empyrion trials glow turns red
when equipped light breakers wear this
emblem when trying to block players from
getting to the lighthouse
to see now they've actually that but
it's really just an emblem it doesn't
mean like is it it's just gonna change
the color of your glow it's like are
they just saying that it's trying to
like in saying that's probably when
you're gonna wear those somebody red
could still carry people they just might
be yeah sending a weird message maybe I
think I think you trying to add
personality so to you know each of each
of the different type of people who play
trials and it's definitely different you
don't say that it's I have no problem
with it you don't say I will say the
shot that curl ass because you got a
good video did I say we might have to be
careful rocking or less colorful stuff
in trials making us look like a neo
outside against then you might want to
meet that on when you're in public
spaces as opposed to really you know say
older and you go black out yeah you do
not put on the laser lightshow
outfit but at did you go stand out yep
that is what we know for trials seven
wins we do have the mercy and you have
the mercy or the boon of the bonus wins
you get a freebie off or you get the
bonus and you think you could do it so
mm-hmm
before it used to be nine you could get
a free loss but even with the bonus
boons you would be like still have to
get seven wins now you've only got to go
six if you actually just go straight
through the top without the mercy what
do you think sixty is short or
still it's but if you go through it out
there that particular big you you still
gonna need that extra one you're still
gonna need the seventh you need seven
unless you go ferocity and then says
with zero losses your third wind grants
a bonus win so right what are you it on
a team at six so you know you Joe right
with the play if you don't play the
mercy you would only need six wins so
it's actually a quicker card than it
used to be that's new okay and what I
like a guy could do I was saying it
could be but you don't have the mercy
and the bonus that's right so there's
restoral prayer correct what I what I
like is that for the hardcore trials guy
again this is not me this is that you
know father said the dudes you know who
are getting they carry on Vanguard do
their guards and you know the fallout
place and all that stuff they are going
to be incentivized to try these
different playstyles you know saying
whether it be aggressive or whatever
with the you know frost they're gonna
they're gonna be creative but that it's
not just oh I'm gonna grab the the
crutch one all the time which is the you
know the mercy revive yourself Ola yeah
I like that aspect I like I like that
ass but it definitely adds a different
layer to it you know I'm saying and we
got stuff to talk about but um get a
hand with it right man they handle it
right this is what you gotta do you
gotta they brought it back but they
added some new flavors because those
type of boons did not exist in the in
the first version yeah a little tweak to
it so not exactly the same but overall
seems pretty good and they did mention
in the 12 sheeting
not gonna tell us what they're doing but
they have definitely done new
server-side security features they've
definitely got to make sure that's a
suspect a cheater report form use that
report um in game they are definitely
doing everything and they can't like
they the game is still set up with the
matchmaking at as it is but sounds like
maybe the steam if info is gonna be
better that's the only ass bro that's
all whether they're trying they're doing
what they can try that I I love that you
know saying because again that was the
biggest concern that was the biggest
this could be a damper on your problems
I've seen they they're not gonna have
any problems cuz no destiny has been
very shaky lately I don't know how have
you been experiencing I've been
experiencing beavers anteaters all tight
I don't know what's going on I'm getting
crashes exiting the game yeah I don't
know if you experienced that like with
rocks I like the fading yeah yeah I'm
like what is going on fellas so yeah
there's been a lot of hard hard closes
in that one yeah
the once you know I heard that stuff for
what is it um you know was it uh let's
trade thought the whole what is it the
own but as I said before the other thing
the last point I just lost but I had a
guarantee or security trial damn I had
the whole thing with it with it with it
with the security joy but anyway it'll
come back but yo this is a good thing
this is a really really good thing don't
I'm I was pleasantly surprised when I
see this but did not think this would
ever happen to be honest not not with
their current setup so this is good man
like I said it's it's definitely them
taking this serious they they want this
mode to be clean they want this to be as
as clear as possible they don't want
anything going on wrong and they're
shady as best as they possibly can
that's all we ask
is there anybody you're looking to watch
play trials this weekend out of
curiosity hmm
I gotta hit fallout up I like fall out
of a full house got a fantastic video
out right now sign set yeah seven you
watched it did you watch the seven rules
don't ya bro - don't get sick don't get
picked it's so it's so real because you
know what I really shocked about I'll
come back to that right quick because um
you know I don't consider it like one of
the best PvP players I play with yeah
but I have good synergy with him and
what I realize is trials is about
synergy who you play with and the thing
I like about it is that you know they're
good like for our business video there
are times people won't you want to make
a hero moment like it I could take them
gonna say oh I got my suit pocket you
know say and sometimes you have to fall
back follow some basic principles to
stay alive and that's what makes it so
fun and I've been doing so much
elimination this week
just getting myself in that mindset
getting myself in that that whole bag
but um yeah man like uh of a hike I'll
pump I'm gonna definitely gonna try to
catch him you know I'm saying I'll
definitely throw my face in there just
to see how it is and who's not gonna
look forward to to say 14 as an
announcer that'll be four you go look
forward to that - for sure that'll be
yeah oh yeah I love I love this stuff
that I love it it it should be an
interesting weekend I will this weekend
verse next weekend I'm also very curious
to Kenna get the feel of everybody and
like the big power differences versus
everybody a little closer kind of
curious how all that eventually pans out
yeah yeah but I see oh oh what's that he
said he say you try to get us that child
trying to get us Indian me in Congress
run can I get a backpack carry with
space for both of us please because I
know I'm gonna smell comedy some bad
family grab scream up for so we'll see
he was doing wings do a work killer if I
was like at some point we might I might
try and do some trial stuff trust me if
I ever do Oh
this weekend busy but I'll definitely
look on trying to do it so
but other than that for the 12 they are
going to look at trying to put some of
these stat displays back in the games on
the emblems I know people kind of
freaked out about it
fractal line donated for the guy who had
like 2 million it's gone there was just
certain things I don't know it's like
didn't need to go away and it's just it
was a weird weird display like kills as
this and then you know gold medals
earned for the PvP beasts and you know
solo flawless hit of heresies and all
those things that people do like if they
have certain ones kind of nice to keep
them up there so we'll be coming back I
know they're trying to make you be like
hey I'll just hang this little baby
banner on my big banner it's like I know
so cool in theory but I was in long run
like people want that quick display like
hey matchmaking damn dude you got like
12,000 gold medals in PvP yeah I'm a
beast like and it's just not there so
they were working on bringing it back
they won't do all of them but they're
listening to feedback trying to bring
back what they can eventually so that's
mostly yeah last point oh now I just
think I think it's just uh this was a
technical issue they were trying to be
cool and and implement a new feature
this just my eye pain I could be wrong
no it'll try to be cool to implement a
cool feature but this new feature
interferes with the old system and now
they have to figure out a way to
implement and again they should have
been transparent and told us this is do
thing they was thinking about doing you
know saying because it's jarring to wake
up to your favorite stats or whatever it
is that you've been tracking not their
you know I'm say it's jarring they wake
up to not know about ritual weapons they
think they had to be a little bit drop
the ball there those two definitely the
community should have known about
yeah it's uh
uh just we say we're getting a whole lot
of transparency Oh what
father bunny like you find out so do we
think we're getting a lot of
transparency would get a season that
just like launches with you know no
ritual weapons and these changes and
sometimes they may hit the nail and then
sometimes just kind of miss oh yeah yeah
that's that's about all I know
mm what about you you got anything else
before you try and get a nap in the play
trials all weekend oh okay go V now
don't try to power through ice I'm
hurting bad right now but I will try to
power through need to get you some luck
gamer substr G fool or foe hey all of
any of you guys were open to sponsors
here we'll break yeah just need us up
there's guy I got some Venus and some
gamers stuff so I'll just combine them
together I will just drill straight and
I'll be good to go
we need that dingy and cheetah flavor
let's go get this up I'll be all for it
for sure but yeah I'm gonna talk about
just again I just need to hear I need to
see just the I just need to see my baby
back in all its glory
and just to him I'll be waiting for the
tweet this weekend for you to have your
helmet sir it's what I'm waiting on oh
I've listened I don't care how I don't
care if I get three wins and it pop up
all I want is my Anubis wolf
oh man if I get that
get my outfit and that's what I missed
that grind you know say your forte your
forte no I'm enough he said go to bed I
just see you or tell you though man I'm
a vampire
yeah but bro I got a stamp this is I
waited too long it's been almost over a
year no trials no like I can't I'm
powering through I'm close to the finish
line because I know what's gonna happen
as soon as I hear say forties boys the
Adrenaline's gonna kick and I'm ready I
am ready ready it's so fun 3v3
elimination one of the most fun modes in
destiny the king is back its backyard
you know sit down I will to your point I
am curious you know
Jonjo society
I am curious to see if it hits like how
in a sense of
immunity driver the numbers like I said
when we pull up Charlotte me how them
numbers gonna look you know I'm saying
maybe they start off strong let's see
how the numbers go you know a month
Nelly you don't say like I'm very
curious to see because we all know when
when trials was trials man was by
remembering with so many PVE droughts
know raised stuff and trials was just
that thing that just kept going kept
going kept going to streamers to twitch
you know all that stuff it's gonna be
interesting if that culture returns
they've did a fantastic job of barking I
mean we got you don't trailer a trailer
information you know it's the it was the
worst kept secret that everybody don't
have to do but on it's good good to see
it just thank God they got the classic
bass back you know I'm saying just
playing those maps this week though but
you see you you coming on the field
feels like what I did here what oh it's
gonna be something man I can't I can't
wait okay I just gotta see my baby
it's qunari ready to go well that's
about all I got so initial impressions
on the season where can I got our first
few days in trials the big other half
that starts in two hours so if there's
guys who listen to this later obviously
we're going before so next week you
won't want to miss the show because then
we'll have more impressions about said
mode getting a little Thai minutes
that's about all I got you got any other
final thoughts or anything before we go
or wrap this thing up and let you uh get
ready get ready to go blow some faces
off look PvE guys don't panic yet I
understand it's all about us right now
but you've had your shine you you gotta
step aside just for this week but this
week got understood it's for your boys
yeah I'm gonna be fine
it's gonna be some secrets there's gonna
be stuff things gonna hook up you know I
just think right now they've got to work
out the transparency kinks the bugs all
the things that are really annoying
people right now
get on that and I think they'll be fine
and then uh it's time to give who's
gonna be worthy mmm is going to be we're
gonna have your [ __ ] you're gonna get
your flawless titled this weekend right
I saw a terribly I'm never getting that
title I saw the requirements I was like
I'm never getting that title like you
got to carry someone someone who's never
beds wasn't there wrong you need a
certain number of wins once your card is
full - that's like the gatekeeper or
some crap and I'm like you're yeah
they're incentivizing people to stay at
seven wins and keep going just as I'm
trying to get to the lighthouse those
like huge chat that get you - that's me
- be yeah that's this that's even people
who are at seven wins the way is to like
let me go ahead and make this harder for
the people who might all I gots a six
yeah you're getting shut down somebody
says like beast mode yeah I see if I
face somebody who's flawless I'm gonna
be like your jerk shout out the bed de
vaisseau you could always can be bro I'm
looking for the carry I'm looking for a
free hand I need I need backs backs face
like the guy in a spin sure who got
carried in on the back like yeah I need
I need me size backpack carried in its
it's not gonna happen any other way it's
oh yeah looking for there's a big foot
mess around with us get stop get spare
hopefully I get five wigs
I'll call five victory there you go baby
Fox 5's decent that's me
oh I would be happy with like three
though I'm pretty out of practice and
all that stuff all right guys we gonna
wrap this thing up and then I'm gonna
send you guys that's the Holtzman is
live he's back in the world so yep babe
yeah so gonna go over and send you guys
to Holtzman once we wrap this thing up
but quick quick outros and then we will
wrap this thing up third gen Yuri no
Lord Cognito like Twitter and um I love
podcasts we turns on Sunday she got my
guests we may have a guest we may have
guys I'm not sure yet I gotta figure it
out it's better it's been a crazy week
but um yeah man please - it will be 1
p.m. Eastern talking the latest in
gaming of the the sadness that is of III
being cancelled most likely will be a
topic as well as some other stuff going
on in the gaming industry
but yeah please check us out and of
course every Friday morning he hates
what I said but I'm gonna say any day
the best destiny podcast you've never
wit my baby but is the last word fix
your face because it is I don't care if
they hear us they will love us they just
say hear us a lot of people just say
here but you'll appreciate to the chat
support you guys always make me laugh
always fun always know the stuff to
tweet buttons to get us going it's it's
all a good fun and I actually love the
community that we started to build it
it's really cool and like I said it's
appreciate the support and that's what I
got in trials his back your boys got his
dream mold back to be happy for me just
be happy for me PvE QT it's my time let
me get this one yeah they would throw it
up for cog this week enjoy so and for me
as this settle get family in town this
weekend so I'm probably not gonna be
around very much but come Monday or
Tuesday of course you guys know where to
find me twitch Twitter YouTube Avant is
everywhere thank you guys you guys are
awesome so this is episode 94 thank you
guys for tuning in March 13th a couple
hours before trials go live so next
episode gonna be an interesting
discussion for sure so thank you guys
for tuning in it's been a great one and
next week should be an awesome one so
for the time being it has been - the
last word